über schallt flugzeuge wie die concorde
ja die sind teuer klein und laut drei
gründe warum sie nicht mehr fliegen doch
kommt jetzt die trendwende können wir
bald alle mit überschall in extrem
kurzer zeit zwischen den kontinenten
reisen unter anderem entwickelt die nasa
mit dem sogenannten schlieren effekt
überschallflugzeugen die viel leiser
sind wie funktioniert diese technik
genau und bedeutet dass jetzt
tatsächlich schon bald die rückkehr der
superschnellen passagierflugzeuge ein
wirklich spannendes thema das ihr euch
bei whatsapp gewünscht habt wie ihr da
hin kommt übrigens weder whatsapp seit
das erfahrt am ende des videos also
herzlich willkommen bei konstanz
entwickeln muss erst mal klarzustellen
der sogenannte schlieren effekt hat
nichts mit missglückten versuchen die
fenster schlierenfrei zu putzen zu tun
tatsächlich wurde dieses verfahren vor
mehr als 150 jahren von einem deutschen
physiker erfunden damit war es erstmals
möglich dichte unterschiede in der luft
auf fotoplatten sichtbar zu machen
die sogenannten schlieren platt gesagt
kann man durch diesen effekt also das
sichtbar machen was das menschliche auge
normalerweise nicht wahrnehmen kann
die luftdichte und ihre veränderungen im
alltag also dinge wie die warme luft
beim haare föhnen oder aber die wärme
die entsteht wenn man die hände
aneinander reibt oder heizungsluft auf
die nasa an nutzt dieses verfahren und
hat es weiterentwickelt so ist es
tatsächlich gelungen bei modernen
überschalljets die druckwelle sichtbar
zu machen also den berühmten
überschallknall und das unter
realistischen umständen und das ist
ziemlich schwierig aus diesen aufnahmen
unter anderem sind leise
überschallflugzeugen jetzt in greifbare
nähe gerückt aber von vorne
normalerweise ist eben ein lauter knall
zu hören wenn ein düsenflugzeug die
schallmauer durchbricht seismometer
können das festhalten denn die
druckwelle des knalls erschüttert den
erdboden das ist wirklich absoluter
wahnsinn früher da konnte man das immer
mal wieder hören irgend unglaublich laut
und das rumpf so richtig doch diese
dichte variationen der luft auf fotos
festzuhalten das war lange nicht möglich
nur in modellen im windkanal die
entsprechenden testflüge der nasa fanden
in der mojave wüste in südkalifornien
stadt pro shooting waren zwei flugzeuge
beteiligt eines der flugzeuge hatte die
aufgabe die schallmauer zu durchbrechen
und eine entsprechende druckwelle zu
erzeugen und zwar abwechselnd die
flugzeugtypen f-15 und t 38 darüber flog
das zweite flugzeug das eine kamera
installiert hatte und in diesem nasa
versuch ist es eine king er die deutlich
langsamer ist und eben nicht in der lage
die schallmauer zu durchbrechen vor
allem die navigation der flugzeuge war
heikel und nicht ungefährlich denn sie
dürften sich trotz der großen
geschwindigkeitsdifferenz nicht so weit
voneinander entfernen damit gute
bildqualität überhaupt möglich wurde die
eingesetzte kamera war in der lage 109
bilder pro sekunde zu machen ein
absolutes unterfangen das alles möglich
zu machen hatte die nasa die
herkömmliche methode namens boss aus dem
windkanal weiter entwickelt bosch steht
für background oriented schweren der
name des nasa projekts dementsprechend
auch airbus die bildbearbeitung an sich
war dagegen weniger spektakulären die
einzelnen frames wurden per laptop
ausgewertet und viele einzel fenstern
zusammengesetzt und diese neue
aufnahmetechnik liefert nicht nur
atemberaubende bilder sondern konnte
auch zeitnah in der praxis genutzt
werden denn bisher ist es
überschallflüge nicht nur in den usa
sondern auch in deutschland verboten
über bewohnten regionen zu fliegen
früher war das anders da konnte man eben
noch den überschallknall ab und zu hören
und zwar eben wegen dieser
lärmbelästigung die nase erhoffte sich
also durch diese neue aufnahmetechnik
deutlich leisere überschallflugzeuges zu
konstruieren und tatsächlich scheint es
so als sei die nasa diesem ziel ziemlich
näher gekommen zu sein vielleicht wissen
dass die nasa-ingenieure teams haben
explain ein flugzeugmodell entwickelt
bei dem die schockwellen deutlich
abgeschwächt sind die bezeichnungen
supersonic transport im gegensatz zur
concorde selten dieses passagierflugzeug
dieses überschall passagierflugzeug nur
einen weichen schuss abgeben wenn es die
schallmauer durchbricht die concorde
brauchte für die strecke
new york/paris ja nur knapp drei stunden
2003 wurde sie dann aber eingestellt
weil die sicherheitsbedenken wegen des
absturzes zu groß und die nachfrage auch
eher klein weil die flüge waren tierisch
teuer
aber eine miniatur version des neuen
nasa überschallflugzeuges wurde schon im
windkanal getestet anfang des monats
macht in die nasa waren ernst und
beauftragte den rüstungskonzern lockheed
martin explain zu entwerfen zu bauen und
zu testen
zwei 147,5 millionen dollar ist der nasa
das wert der big screen soll in 16.000
kilometern höhe fliegen und zwar mit
1500 kilometern pro stunde
seine spezielle bauform soll dann den
lauten knall ferner und zwar indem die
schallwellen nicht miteinander
verschmelzen sondern in kleine stücke
zerteilt werden im jahr 2022 soll dann
das endgültige passagierflugzeug
getestet werden dass für die bevölkerung
auf der erde nicht lauter sein soll als
einen zufallende autotür oder ein
donnergrollen hammer überschallflüge
rücken also wieder in greifbare nähe und
möglich gemacht hat das die schweren
fotografie
das ist schon irre wenn ihr als erstes
neues zum fortschritt bei den über
einfügen und zu allen anderen themen
erfahren wollt dann endet meine
telefonnummer hier bei whatsapp dann
erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen
vom neuesten video garantiert ihr können
dort auch mitmachen und mir zum beispiel
themen vorschlagen und so weiter und so
fort und zur begrüßung gibt es noch ein
kleines geschenk einfach hier
draufklicken und natürlich nicht das
aber mit der denn auch glocke vergessen
hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch noch
blicken flughafen der zukunft ansonsten
bis dann lauter